here is video of our Department of
Homeland and security secretary
Alejandro mayorkas basically saying that
there is a reason that we're not
protecting the Border kind of sort of
maybe
the first weeks in office the Biden
Administration halted deportations for
100 days stopped all border wall
construction and suspended the remaining
Mexico policy critics say it all added
up to putting a come in we're open sign
on the door I don't think that the more
than million people last year that we
removed or expelled would consider the
Border open but the messaging was the
messaging wrong there that you know
we're open that wasn't our messaging but
that was the but that's the migrants
were getting because remember something
that we are not the only source of
messages that the migrants receive
okay I don't know what he means by that
but the point is we know you guys know
it we didn't even have to show you more
Clips on this the amount of uh border
crossings that are happening right now
millions of them were this year than if
you took the last couple years combined
and certainly way more than When Donald
Trump was was president but what did
they do when Donald Trump said he was
going to build a wall and why was he
going to build a wall you either have a
country or you don't you a country is a
nation-state that has a delineated
border from another country so we are
not Mexico there is a There's an actual
border it's an agreed upon border by
both countries right and if you cross
that border illegally you have now
broken the law and we are allowed to
kick you out that's what a mature
responsible country would do that's what
countries in Eastern Europe are doing
right now that's what countries like
Poland and Hungary are doing they're
saying we are going to protect our
borders we don't care if you call us
races blah blah blah when Trump tried to
do it basically the entire system tried
to take him out I think you can see how
this is connected to where we started
with it showed that these are these are
unserious people these are not people
who want to celebrate doing what is
right and getting out there and getting
yours and and having Law and Order
because that's a piece of your ability
to get out there and get yours but why
doesn't majorcus think that Biden wants
a border here there's a great answer on
this one this is this is just like
wizard level go ahead
is there anything that's off the table
that you won't do to secure the Border
well the president uh as I think you
know very well is that we are not going
to construct more wall that costs
billions and billions of dollars that is
immovable
is there anything you won't do yeah I
won't build a wall
because that's the thing that would
probably do it that does make it much
more complex by the way I'm not even
sitting here telling you that a wall
completely is the way to do it you know
you'd also have to use imminent domain
to move farms and move people out of
their houses on certain border areas
there might be a lot of ways that we can
do it electronically and with certain
levels of monitoring and have a certain
amount of of military down there and
everything else but like the one thing
we will do is the wall
[Music]
thank you